while the blockade at the coots border
crossing is gone the investigation into
those responsible for it is ramping up
with police now digging into what's
being described as a small organized
group of protesters with a militant
mindset and the ability to get their
hands on these
long guns handguns ammunition and body
armor the dangerous criminal activity
occurring away from the tv cameras and
social media posts was real and
organized
and it could have been deadly for
citizens protesters and officers among
the 13 people arrested four face the
most serious charges of conspiracy to
commit murder accused of plotting to
murder rcmp officers in connection with
the protest we're talking about a group
that is organized
agile
knowledgeable and driven by an extremist
ideology we need police officers as well
who will have the courage to resist
unlawful orders and global news has
learned some protesters intended to
expand their efforts all the way to
ottawa if the government of alberta
thinks that the protest is over and the
threat is gone
then they're more more naive than i even
thought neil lamay is a retired mountie
with 30 years of policing experience his
security firm found some protesters so
emboldened they discussed targeting
critical infrastructure nationally
including airport cargo terminals and
leaning into religion and far-right
ideologies to recruit it is extensively
quoting the bible for justifications to
take up arms against the government to
overthrow the government right now
alberta rcmp releasing few details about
those charged or whether there may be
more arrests to come
trace negai global news calgary